he's an American entrepreneur author and
speaker he's widely respected as one of
the world's most well known and
respected internet marketers
he teaches through a mix of video
training webinars written guides
one-on-one training and seminars
he's Evan pagan and here are his top ten
rules for success
he says rich is a state of mind and then
if you're rich on the inside you can
then go create money but if you're not
rich on the inside if you don't have a
rich state of mind not only will you not
be able to attract and create money but
if you do get some you'll find a way to
get rid of it right a way that I have of
saying it is that there's a big
difference between money and wealth and
wealth comes from having knowledge
systems assets understanding of how to
create value for others and having
systems and assets that create value
whereas money is just these you know
imaginary numbers and these worthless
piece of paper that we you know try to
pretend to have value so success is
about fulfillment and I think
fulfillment is about creating success
for yourself but then creating success
for others and helping them succeed have
you ever seen Stephen Covey talking
about how you have to put the big rocks
in your day or else they will they won't
go in and so what he'll do is they take
he takes a big fish tank and on the
table he has some big rocks and then he
has some smaller rocks and then he has
some pebbles and then he has some sand
okay and so what he does is first he
starts by putting all the sand into the
tank and then he puts in the the little
pebbles and then he puts in the bigger
rocks and by the time he's done the tank
is almost full and he can't fit in the
big rocks that he has they just kind of
sit on top and there's nowhere to put
most of them but then what he does is he
takes the big rocks and he puts them
into the tank first and then he takes
the smaller rocks and he puts them in
and he fits them around the bigger rocks
then he takes the little pebbles and he
puts them in and they fit in around the
this
all the rocks and the bigger ones and
then he pours a ton of sand in there
which fills all the cracks up and the
lesson is that you have to put in the
big rocks first or else they'll never go
in okay and the interesting thing about
the big rocks is that they have to be
chosen in advance in other words you
must identify what your most valuable
activities are and then install them in
your day ahead of time because if you
don't okay other people will have things
for you to do other people will take
your attention and I can almost
guarantee you that these other things
that other people have for you are less
important but in the moment they seem a
lot more urgent okay so you got to put
the big rocks in first and very
importantly you have to know what they
are don't keep your best ideas secret
most of the business owners that I know
whenever they figure out something
that's really fantastic a thing that
would really help prospects out they
start scheming about how to sell it for
a lot of money and about how to get
people to give them money before they
reveal this secret to them or this
product or this service or this this
information well guess what if you don't
show people what you've got and you
don't prove to them that you have a lot
of value they're not going to pay any
attention to you at all a different
mindset that I've developed and learned
over the last several years is that if
you will take your best ideas the ones
that are the most valuable the ones that
you might consider to be the silver
bullets
the magic bullets the ones that work
every time that give instant results
that eliminate hassle and friction from
a person's life and you give those away
the prospect will say to themselves oh
geez if this is what they're giving way
how much better must be the product that
they're selling so the advice that I
have for you is ask yourself right now
what is the one thing that you've
figured out over your lifetime and over
your career that can help your prospects
out the most the thing that can give
them the most value eliminate the most
friction and hassle from their life all
right the thing that works every single
time what's the magic bullet that you
figured out
the one thing before you heard this you
would never share with anyone okay good
I'd like you to do now is make a
commitment to yourself to give it away
and give it away to as many people as
you possibly can
by the way this is the kind of thing
that will create viral marketing for you
this is the kind of thing that you give
it away people will start talking about
it they'll start coming to you and
saying wow that's an incredible idea do
you have any more and I advise you to
give away even more of your good ideas
now language is part of communication
but there's a much bigger piece of
communication than language which is the
nonverbal communication that happens
between people most persuasion most
bonding most connection happens on
channels other than the words alright so
you've heard the the old estimates that
you know over 90 percent of your
communication is your voice tone in your
body language communication is so
important and what's amazing is most
people are just unconscious they're not
paying any attention to it they're not
learning how to communicate with and
connect with other people better so
learn about body language learn about
nonverbal communication learn about how
to connect with people and build rapport
so I think of entrepreneurship as being
like an ultimate training ground an
ultimate practice place to learn the
basic skills that we need to learn in
order to then come back and and be great
at contribution Steven Covey has the
model of first we start out dependent
and then we become independent and then
we become interdependent and in
developmental models if you study
developmental psychology which I
recommend you do in any of the
developmental models each level acts as
a foundation for the next level so if we
don't become powerfully independent we
can't become powerfully interdependent
and I think of entrepreneurship is being
the best school now for becoming
powerfully independent Robert Kiyosaki
who wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad and cashflow
quadrant some other books that are
excellent initial training he's got this
some this model where he says we start
out as employee
and then we go to self-employed and then
we become business owners and then we
become investors and then I would add
then we become philanthropists ideally
we'd become people to come back and
contribute and these build upon each
other ok so when you're an employee you
are you learn some tasks some skills you
do them you get a paycheck when you
become self-employed
now you're responsible you have to go
get the business as well then when you
have a when you're a business owner you
create that organism or that entity that
then runs and throws off the profit and
then when you become an investor you
invest in those types of entities and
then ideally when you become a
philanthropist or someone that's
contributing you start investing in the
most important you know biggest why to
scale up kind of projects and I say that
model those five steps because
entrepreneur business owner is in the
middle and what I want to emphasize is
that entrepreneurship and owning and
building a business it's one step in a
much bigger puzzle it's not the end and
unfortunately I see a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck at that step
they get to that level and they start
becoming very successful and then they
just want more and bigger and you know
more money and more power rather than
realizing oh that's just one step that I
need to become competent in so that I
can go on to the next level and go on to
the next level so what's the difference
between these levels well essentially
the difference is each one becomes more
complex and more multi-dimensional and
has a longer time horizon right so when
you're an employee you're just doing
your work to get your paycheck in two
weeks when you're self-employed all of a
sudden the timer as it moves out you
learn about invoicing and you learn that
companies don't pay invoices as fast as
you used to get your paycheck and then
when you become a business owner an
entrepreneur you know kind of proper you
start thinking in timeframes of months
in years in terms of return you become
an investor you start thinking in terms
of multiple years or even decades and
then philanthropist you know you look
way out onto the horizon and and I say
this because because each level builds
on the previous levels this
entrepreneur level where you you start
learning to manage a team to manage
resources to think in multi-year time
horizons it's a really important step
for us to all go through and when I hear
people tell me that they want to make an
impact on the world and they go straight
from you know high school to that or
sometimes straight from college to that
and they don't get a little experience
working in the entrepreneurial world my
heart sinks a little bit because I think
they're not going to be as powerful at
making a difference or an impact in the
world as they would have been had they
gone and made themselves strong and
powerful and successful first start
habitual izing or ritualizing or
systemising or routine izing those
things that are the most important
things and start doing them every day at
the same time and what you'll find is
that especially in the work arena in
business if you will make rituals and
routines out of the very high value
things in your life every day you'll do
them at the same time automatically
because if you think about it you
already do the same things every day at
the same time automatically when we
procrastinate what we're usually doing
is resisting doing something different
than we normally do right we have our
routines that we're in we're all
creatures of habit we like to do the
same things at around the same times
every day and when we're procrastinating
what we're doing is going oh I don't
really want to do that thing right now
sometimes we don't know why we're coming
up with a bunch of excuses it's usually
just because it's not a habit it's not a
routine it's not something that we do
automatically every day as an example I
struggled for years with trying to get
my sleep and my exercise and my diet all
in shape well that all changed when I
built a simple routine where I go to
sleep at the same time I wake up around
the same time and then I do my exercise
first thing and then I eat a healthy
meal first thing and then I just made a
routine out of that so I go to sleep
I get enough sleep I wake up first thing
that I do is I make sure that I get my
exercise and then I have a healthy meal
and now I'm pulled
into these routines everyday and they
don't have to worry about
procrastinating because it's a ritual
it's something that I do the same every
day now it takes 30 days or so to
actually create a new habit so you got
to force yourself to do it at the same
time every day
at two to three weeks you'll notice it
gets easier and easier and then in about
a month you're just doing the exact same
thing every day you're pulled into it
you find yourself doing it automatically
and this is the one where Ellen goes oh
I don't want to be a salesperson right
yeah one of the things that we do in our
business is we take experts and we teach
them how to package their information up
into products like ebooks and other
information products and sell them well
when I start talking to these experts
almost universally they say things like
I've got all the content I just need to
find someone who can mark it and sell it
for me and when I say to them well you
know what would probably be good for you
is to actually learn some marketing and
sales they go oh I don't want to look
I'm not a Salesman they kind of like
look down it salespeople like it's some
like lower form of human business scum
or something like that and you know you
imagine okay I have to put on a funky
like a weird suit and like a windbreaker
like a car salesman or the sell my
product would never want to do that well
when you really learn sales as I know
you know because your various or your
fantastic sales person that the best
selling methods are consultative selling
where you don't sit down and try to talk
someone into buying you sit down and you
say let me ask you some questions let me
learn about you and find out what all
your problems are and let me see if what
I have is even a fit and then once
you've found out where they're at what
their problems are what all the
challenges they're facing or and what
they'd like to accomplish then you sell
solutions you sell them fixing their
problems you sell them getting what they
want not your thing and the best of the
best of the best salespeople are the
ones that walk in and sit down and ask
much questions and then say my product
can't help you let me refer to some you
know refer you to someone who can
because those are the people that win
the trust and
when they say this is the thing that
will solve your problem the prospects is
that's the thing I need because they're
trustworthy so learning consultative
selling and really learning how to sell
like a professional is very important
know thyself know thyself
this is probably the most famous phrase
handed down from the Greek philosophers
know thyself why is it so important why
is it so profound
and another question why do we do what
we do why do we think the way we think
why do we feel the way we feel why do we
behave in certain patterns and get into
certain relationship patterns in our
lives well these are the magic questions
psychology answers these questions on
the general level but we all have
experiences that are private very
individual and very powerful we have
something that's shaping our thoughts
shaping our emotions shaping our
behavior from the inside why is it so
important to know yourself what does it
mean well I don't think it means to know
what your favorite TV show is or what
your favorite restaurant is I do think
to know yourself means to understand
your personality to understand how
you're wired what you're likely to do in
different situations under different
types of pressure and with different
types of people the reason that it's so
important to know thyself is because
there are many different types of people
in the world and to create success you
must work effectively with yourself and
with others you must know yourself you
must know how you work so you can
control yourself communicate well and
understand what others are communicating
and ultimately increase your
effectiveness communicating and
persuading others and creating the
results that you want in your life it's
also critical to know yourself so you
can understand your weaknesses your soft
spots your Achilles heels and those
things in your life that can hurt you
all of these things are intimately
connected to your personality
understanding your personality is
understanding yourself if you'd like to
know thyself then know thy personality
in the past the paradigm that we use as
business owners and marketers is that we
have some entry-level stuff that we use
to get prospects attention and those
things might be like advertisements or
we might offer you know some free
information or a free report or
sometimes even pre-recorded messages or
free consultations and then we move and
we have the kind of mid-level priced
products that we sell and upsell to and
then we have our highest end products
that we sell to our best customers well
what's happening now and what's
happening a lot and accelerating over
the last few years with the rise of the
Internet
is more and more stuff is available for
free there are more companies that are
funded by venture capital that have 50
million dollars in cash in the bank that
they don't know what to do with so
they're just giving stuff away to
customers things are becoming cheaper
and cheaper to produce and all that
stuff that you used to think of as being
your your real valuable stuff now you've
got your competitors giving it away to
your customers so if you can't beat them
you need to join them and in fact what I
think you need to do is get in front of
them and what we do is we take that line
that was the stuff that we used to give
away for free and we move it deeper into
the customer relationship and the things
that we used to charge money for are
entry-level products now we give away
and what that does is it builds
relationships with more customers it
allows us to kind of widen our funnel so
to speak and attract a lot more
prospects so let me give you an example
from one of our current businesses as I
mentioned before we have a company
called double your dating and in that
company we teach dating advice to men
now we actually have another company
that we teach dating advice to women and
we have others that we teach other kind
of self-help and personal development
topics but the one that started it all
was the company called double your
dating and when I originally sat down to
work on the marketing for that that
company I started playing around with
email newsletters and at first the
newsletters that I sent out were very
short and there were excerpts of some of
our products and other stuff that wasn't
really all that valuable but it was free
and I thought that people would you know
kind of find it find some value in it we
started sending them out well as we
developed I started writing longer and
longer newsletters and I realized that
the more valuable the newsletter the
more it caused people to want to invest
in our products and at one point I said
to myself you know what I want to create
the most valuable newsletter that has
ever been created on any topic ever in
history and then I want to give it away
I set the bar very high
and when I was thinking this I was
thinking about financial newsletters
that sometimes cost thousands of dollars
a year I mean I was really put in the
bar up there and if you've ever read
some of our newsletters you'll see that
they average probably fifteen or twenty
pages long and we send them out every
couple
days some of them are as long as 30 or
40 pages of value jam-packed with
entertaining useful step-by-step
mindsets everything you could possibly
need and we get letters from all around
the world constantly talking about how
the appreciation thanking us for the
value that we jam-pack in these
newsletters if you subscribe to that
newsletter and you're interested in
getting dating advice you will have your
picture filled up to the brim I
recommend that you ask yourself how can
you move the free line in your business
you might not want to go overboard like
we did but what's an entry level product
that doesn't cost you much to produce
that you can just give away to your
customers if you don't use information
products in your business things like
email newsletters and downloadable
ebooks and CD and DVD courses and
streaming video like you're watching
right now then you really need to do
that and you need to learn about it as
soon as you possibly can the idea of
bringing light to failures right and you
mentioned that in our business we try to
encourage people as soon as you see
something that goes wrong or you screw
something up raise your hand it's a half
screwed-up or I see something that's
wrong over here and make it a win and I
just want to just slip this in there a
reason why that's so important is that
we humans don't like to look bad in
front of others we don't like to look
like idiots we don't like to screw screw
things up so what we do in a business or
a corporate environment is we screw
something up and then we take it and we
hide it and we isolate we try to not let
anyone see it
we try to go to work fixing it
unfortunately if you've screwed
something up it probably means that you
didn't know how to do it right the first
time and it probably also means further
that if you take it and isolate and try
to fix it you're probably can even make
it worse and if you let people have that
mentality of you're going to get in
trouble if you screw something up
they're going to isolate they're going
to go try to fix it they're going to
make it worse
and then when they show up and it gets
discovered they might try to use a
scapegoat and say it wasn't my fault or
someone else did it and you know it's
just a really bad situation so if you
can make an environment or culture we're
finding screw-ups raising your hand when
something goes wrong
saying I made a mistake is a win and the
person to spot the screw-up
the fastest is the biggest winner then I
think you can move forward very quickly
and you can as W Edwards Deming said you
can drive out fear which is one of the
most important things you can do in an
organization thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
Corpus forte asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which if Evan
pagans top 10 rules hit you the hardest
leave it in the comments and I'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon